dix huit mois environ on voit en france
des hommes et des dames aussi bien
qu'ils ont sur les oreilles un casque
leur permettant d'écouter la musique
même dans les bruits de la circulation
ce sont des walkman pas les longues dit
qu'un certain akio morita voulez écouter
de la musique lorsqu'il joue au golf
ça tombait plutôt bien puisqu'il y avait
dans son entreprise un petit service de
recherche et développement ah oui j'ai
oublié de vous dire qu'il s'était or
c'était juste un des co fondateurs de
sony et le 1er janvier 1979 sort au
japon le premier walkman workbook même
wattman walkman et plus rien ne sera
comme avant
non pour les connaisseurs le lecteur de
cassettes stéréophonie est devenu
l'indispensable signe d'appartenance à
une certaine caste image de marque ils
véhiculent et celle de l'action de la
jeunesse et du dynamisme
allez faut que les responsables
marketing et financier de sony ne crois
pas aux produits
akio morita devra faire preuve de
conviction et un peu de fermeté
c'est qui le patron deux ans à peine
après sa sortie en france on compte déjà
1 million de personnes qui possèdent un
rock même si ça c'est pas un succès pour
la petite anecdote se niveler que son
baladeur et des noms différents pour
chaque pays
mais à peine sorti au japon le monde
entier parlait déjà du walkman alors la
marque a décidé de garder ce nom pour
tout le monde tout le monde parce qu'en
fait le monde entier le jeu de mots le
monde tout le monde on avait pu le
budget pour l'auteur ah oui c'est vrai
pour la plupart d'entre vous vous ne
connaissez pas le monde d'avant à cette
époque lorsqu'une marque lancer un
produit ça sortait pays par pays
c'était rare les sorties mondiales la
communication et les échanges n'était
pas aussi rapide qu'aujourd'hui au début
des années 80 pas d'internet en france
on compte que trois chaînes de télé ça
vite fait le tour et quelques magazines
papiers spécialisés
autant vous dire que pour chercher une
information ou un nouveau produit bah il
fallait un peu plus de temps que de
taper une recherche sur google par
exemple pour frimer auprès de vos amis
vous pouviez dire que vous aviez importé
cet appareil avant tout le monde
mieux que vous l'aviez acheté pendant
vos vacances ce qui était bien c'est que
les produits arrivés genre six mois un
an après leur sortie à free mais à
l'époque ça avait une autre gueule à
partir de 1979 le paysage urbain va
définitivement changer
désormais il faudra s'habituer à ces
gens coupés du monde
casque sur la tête le walkman dans le
métro qu'est ce que ça représente assez
important parce que
tu parles tu vois là c'est triste mais
trop les gens en pensent
la musique
rock aussi et tout ça détend c'est
vraiment important
c'est une façon de se couper du monde ou
c'est une façon de couper du monde
croyait puis aussi
j'aime bien la musique j'écoute ce que
j'aime puisque j'ai cassé que
j'enregistre suis bien tu ne te moque
pas c'est le look des années 80 pendant
deux décennies le walkman est l'objet
incontournable des années 80-90 le jeune
possède un baladeur danger écoutez de la
musique aussi fort que ça au dessus de
90 décibels plus de deux heures
d'affilée par jour c'est mortel pour les
oreilles au bout de cinq ou six ans on
risque une surdité importante et
définitive et ouais les effets
secondaires liés au walkman c'est la
surdité et la sécurité au volant on en
parle oui parce qu'au début le vide
juridique oblige on pouvait rouler avec
un casque sur la tête un casque sur la
tête
jeu de mots est tout aussi dangereux les
baladeur cassette en voiture même si
aucune loi n'interdit lusage les
responsables de la sécurité routière
tire la sonnette d'alarmé c'est
l'extérieur qui nous avertit du danger
et se rendre sourd artificiellement est
incompatible avec la conduite sur route
parce qu'on a othman qui nous empêche de
voir les voitures ni les piétons
non je prends pas ce soit dangereux non
mais si une ambulance arrive et klaxons
vous n'entendez pas ah ben non ça je la
vois quand même will you save à elle la
voit la voiture ça va elle la voix
superbe en 1985 apparaît le dic sman
c'est le même principe mais en version
cd pas super pratique parce que si tu
bouges et un peu trop calmes ou moins un
peu trop brusque
le disque sauter autant dire que faire
un footing
etc indique sman c'était pas très
pratique malgré cette petite concurrence
technique le baladeur cassette traverse
deux décennies sans encombre mais à la
fin des années 1990 il est abandonné en
faveur des nouvelles technologies
émergentes le minidisc de décès c'est
bon et ils ont pas marqué l'histoire par
contre lui il a fait mal au baladeur
cassette un très très mal dans les
années 2000 la cassette audio analogique
devient obsolète et en octobre 2010 sony
annonce la fin de la commercialisation
de son baladeur cassette
en trente ans la marque aura vendu 220
millions d'exemplaires dans le monde et
je vous parle que de sony pavot du
canton tout une mode
oui mais une mode peut être pas sans
conséquences il ne s'agit pas d' éviter
aux autres le bruit que l'on peut faire
mais de s'éviter à soit le bruit et la
présence des autres
pour les psychiatres c'est une nouvelle
rupture plus grave que celle des
générations alors ce danseur ou walkman
fait-il un pas en arrière ou un pas en
avant